Mr Wallace what power do you think the
West has to stop what President Putin is
doing without starting World War III
well we can help support which we have
done in the United Kingdom has been in
the lead the ability for Ukrainian armed
forces and indeed the whole population
to defend itself that's why we have
equipped actually from a British point
of view for some months the ukrainians
with anti-tank missiles and other weapon
systems and non-lethal Aid and that's
why last week last Friday I hosted a
donor Conference of nearly 30 countries
from NATO and non-nato to try and
collect up as much lethal Aid and
non-lethal as possible to make sure they
can do that so that's the first thing I
think the second thing is as you've seen
across the International Community very
very strong raft of sanctions you know
we have seen sanctions that I haven't
seen before the Russian Central Bank has
been sanctioned a number of Russian
banks with their assets have been frozen
you know that is going to cost the
Russian government and the Kremlin a lot
and it's going to reflect into the
economy of Russia almost immediately I
think we saw twenty thirty percent of
the rubles value drop we saw interest
rates nearly double so the International
Community has shown how very angry it is
with what's going on Ukraine both
economically and from many US in Europe
the sort of military point of view and
and I think you know those two things
are one of the reasons why we see the
Russian armed forces moving very slowly
on its objectives it is behind schedule
considerably and while we've seen some
footage today in karkov of of Russian
forces potentially in the middle of the
city they don't hold the city it's a
city of 1.4 million people and they are
taking casualties the Russians and
they're finding it very slow going
let's we'll go back to to what we know
about actually what's happening on the
ground um in a moment but but first you
mentioned sanctions do you not think the
President Putin will have factored in if
there would have been sanctions and that
these sanctions would have been enormous
and that he actually doesn't care about
Russia being on the Pariah state
but I think firstly I think he probably
looked and sanctions the West put in
place in 2014 and calculated with his
large cash reserves that he would be
able to survive that type of repeat and
while some of those sanctions even 2014
still exist I think he probably planned
on them being ratcheted up I don't think
he would have woken up earlier you know
a few days ago and realize and recognize
that actually the Swift system did
manage to kick Russia out and has taken
a decision to sanction a central bank I
think that would have been Way Beyond
the expectations of the Russian system
but I think and on your last point you
know I think what we have to remember
here is President Putin believed that
these people would welcome him as a
liberator he was convinced in his own
mind and his own writings that the
Russians and the ukrainians were the
same peoples and all they were waiting
for is the great czars or the or the
president of Russia to come and liberate
them and of course when you make that
assumption you make all the decisions
that we see playing out on our
television screen which is a sort of
arrogant armed forces that has got
bogged down ill-prepared Young Junior
soldiers because the officers just
thought this was going to be much easier
than it was you see equipment in the
wrong places and I think that's why he
is you know carrying on as he does but
your very last bit about does he care
well he obviously doesn't really care I
mean when I went to Russia myself the
Russian Ministry of Defense they were
very clear that Russian people could
suffer greater than mine or greater than
Europeans we can't be harmed by
sanctions and I remember saying at one
stage I actually don't want Russian
people to suffer any more than I want
European and British people to suffer
that's my view I don't none of us should
want that but I think there's definitely
a sense of
Pride that somehow Russian suffering
equals Russian leadership and I think
he's about to be shocked because this is
the 21st century and Russian people just
like European people don't want to go
through what they're about to go through
in terms of what is happening on the
ground do you have any understanding or
any information about why this Convoy
approaching Kiev appears to have stalled
is it do we think logistical issues
fueling for example or you know getting
getting supplies to them
or is it possibly a tactical thing to
wait well I think it's a combination of
all of what you above effectively that
what we have seen is that they weren't
properly their tactics weren't correct
they were doing things uh you know
thought they they were rather confident
they would take many of these cities in
a few hours rather than six days or
longer and when any army on the Move uh
has to do takes longer to do things your
logistical supply chain is stretched you
know if you if you're given enough
rations for two days and it takes you
six you suddenly got a problem and I
think what we've seen is a lot of those
issues are coming to Bear they've also
been surprised by the Ukrainian strength
of the resistance and indeed as a result
you know the ukrainians have been also
carrying out a very clever plan we've
seen footage we can't verify but we've
seen footage of you know ukrainians
using uavs to attack petrol uh train
convoys to go after logistical lines
we've seen railway lines blown up all
the things that you and I you know think
of about when it comes to resistance so
I think that is effectively coming home
to roost but it is also a switch in
Russian tactics I think the Russians
have realized that the ukrainians by
fighting are costing them lots and lots
of casualties and the Russians have
taken significant casualties uh far more
than they would have planned and I think
what they are therefore doing is trying
to switch tactics and what you're seeing
now is those heavy bombardments at night
they'll they'll try they won't come into
the cities as much they will I'm afraid
as we've seen tragically well the looks
of things carpet bomb cities uh
indiscriminately in some cases they will
fly their Air at night rather than
daytime because what we've seen is they
get shot down in the daytime and they
will try it slowly but surely try and
surround the cities and then either
bypass them or bombard them and I think
you know that is the brutality that I'm
afraid we are witnessing and it's going
to get worse I've worn before in your
program that that is you know the
Russian Doctrine is to get harder and
tougher and more indiscriminate and
that's why you know that tragic strike
on obviously the cemetery in the in the
Ascension of Kiev uh is exactly what we
should expect more of
you know you talked about carpet farm
and cluster Munitions have been used
thermobaric weapons have been used are
you confident that they have
uh we will collect the evidence on on a
range of those uh usage a number of
international Partners such as Canada
are quite rightly putting lots of effort
in collecting evidence if there was any
evidence of war crimes that would be
either presented to the international
criminal court or indeed countries on
their own are free to take certain
actions uh you know we have to you know
war crimes or anything else are done
based on evidence we've seen reports
we've certainly seen the deployment of
some of those weapon systems uh we
haven't verified the use but that's why
we will collect evidence for it and um
you know some of these weapon systems
are horrendous about a week ago we
summoned the defense attache from the
Russian Embassy to the ministry to
remind him of his obligations under the
Geneva Convention the Geneva Convention
is there to uphold a humanitarian
treatment of both prisoners of War but
also of Civilian populations they have
to live up to those obligations and we
will make sure that we hold them to
account whatever happens whether it's
now or in years to come
Boris Johnson was held to account
personally Yesterday by a Ukrainian
journalist who wanted him to explain to
her why Britain can't enforce a no-fly
zone over Ukraine
why can't we
well I've been on your program about
four times the last week and I've
explained why uh the reason is I'm
afraid uh simple but it is you know very
difficult to take that course but it is
the course we have to take which is if
you have a no-fly zone you have to
enforce a no-fly zone that would involve
British fighter jets shooting down
Russian fighter jets probably over
Ukraine that would lead to Article 5
triggering of NATO and NATO is a
self-defense pact all 30 countries will
come to each other's Aid the triggering
of that article 5 would lead to a war
against Russia across the whole of
Europe that is not a position that
members of NATO are prepared to go that
is why one of the reasons you know
Russia does not want countries to join
NATO because once they are in NATO this
self-defense mechanism is strong it's
why we're reinforcing and indeed
reassuring our friends in places like
the Baltic states who are in NATO but
are on the edge of Russia but that is
the reality of it and we can do the next
best thing and that's not a great
comfort I understand to Ukraine but we
can arm them we can support them uh we
can use bring convene the International
Community to condemn Russia to put in
very large sanctions to freeze their
assets to Target the leaders of that
country and you know whatever happens in
Ukraine and I hope Russia sees sense I
hope it realizes this is not a way
forward but whatever happens in Ukraine
you know the Russian government we see
before us today on our television
screens will be isolated and you know as
I think one of your as Diana said in
Moscow you know Russians were saying we
don't want to be North Korea but you
know if they're not careful they the the
long-term effect on the Russian
government will be isolation
but it seems to me you know as I stand
here on the Ukrainian border and watch
these families coming across I saw a
family three generations coming across a
short time ago the grandmother in tears
you're you know reminding us all how
Britain must play by the rules
playing by the rules how far does he
have to go in breaking the rules before
we take some kind of direct action
well I think the question is how far
does Europe want us to get towards a war
across Europe
um with Russia how far does the British
public want us to go uh in the against a
nuclear armed power who may view
escalation of all means so I think we
have to be realistic here Ukraine and
I've said it even before this conflict
started Britain is at the Forefront of
helping try and get Ukraine into NATO it
takes all 30 countries to support it
we've had troops in Ukraine
through operational orbital since 2014
2015 helping the Ukrainian to train
we've trained 20 000 troops to get them
up to standard to join NATO we've done a
lot of that but others wanted to move at
a different pace so the reality is on
the day that Russia invaded Ukraine a
week ago
Ukraine was not in NATO so we have to do
everything else in our power to do that
but I'm afraid I'm not going to sit here
and say I'm going to put at risk the
rest of Europe by triggering a major
potentially War across the whole
continent
is the UK able to send planes to allow
ukrainians to enforce the no-fly zone
themselves
well look there isn't a no-fly zone so
let's just be really clear here and and
the other thing that no one seems to
talk about in the no-fly zone is who
does the no-fly zone benefit if you had
a no-fly zone in Ukraine the
overwhelming scale of the Russian army
would be able to drive around with
impunity which it can't at the moment
you talked about the armored column
without any air attack from the
ukrainians because there would be a
no-fly zone uh so it's a bit like in 19
you know the Battle of Britain if we
said oh let's have a no-fly zone of a
you know an unhelpful suggestion came
around saying let's not have a note
let's have a no-fly zone that would have
suited the vast you know German Vermont
Army uh we wouldn't have suited the
small uh you know the United Kingdom who
had just not far not previously just
returned back from Dunkirk so so you
know it let's let's ask ourselves what
would it have achieved you can still
have fighting with a no-fly zone it just
won't be in the air and that would allow
those Russian armored columns to drive
around with impunity and not be struck
from the air where currently uh
Ukrainian aircraft and Ukrainian uh
unmanned air vehicles are causing damage
on key parts of their logistical chain
so I think we should people who suggest
a no-fly zone should be really clear
what they're trying to achieve and how
it will be enforced because I don't see
them actually coming up with any logical
details behind it